you
hi everyone welcome to cloud on era live
webinars from Google cloud we're hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is anita
kevin grouchy and today we'll be talking
about how to accelerate insights with
external datasets and Google cloud
platform we be excited today to be
joined by Craig he's actually one of our
data providers from weather source and
he's part of the commercial data set
program here at Google cloud so Craig
did you develop it hello everybody
thanks for attending the webinar today
my name is Craig stomach and I'm the
senior vice president of business
development at weather source great
thanks Greg you can ask questions any
time of the platform and we have
Googlers on standby to answer them so
let's get started so quickly on our
agenda today the first thing we'll start
looking at is the data analytics
landscape next I will introduce the
public and commercial data set programs
and then next I will give it to Craig
who will talk about the GCP data
provider program and then talk about
weather source you'll also go through a
demo and then finally we'll open it up
to live audience Q&A so let's say I'm a
pharmaceutical company and I'm actually
thinking of building some smart inhalers
and the idea behind this is that I want
to predict when asthma triggers or car
right and the first thing I'm sure you
will start thinking about is that these
smart inhalers definitely need to have
some sensors embedded on them and part
of these sensors as you can think about
it will start collecting a lot of
patient data they'll be collecting a lot
of like frequency of attacks
how much usage is being done some
medication usage patient vitals if you
think about it too if we were to do some
type of predictive analytics then we'll
need some form of weather data you know
if we're looking at temperature
allergens in the air and then of course
we'll need some data from disease
surveillance data region specific data
and then even just a virus outbreak data
right the idea behind this is that when
you're starting to think about doing
predictive analysis then
you need all types of different datasets
to be able to do this type of analysis
and which makes a lot of sense so you
will have sources from internal which is
a lot of would be what's collected by
the smart inhalers
but in at the same time you will need to
tap into all these other plethora of
datasets that will be provided by
different sets of providers so we'll
take a quick step back right and we'll
look at the the landscape right now I
mean there is a lot of data being
produced right now and according to IDC
there will be a hundred and sixty three
terabytes of data by 2025 for me this is
a lot of data I can't even imagine right
I mean we're looking at a lot of
unstructured data being introduced a lot
of selfies as you can think about lots
of cat videos right how do we start to
analyze that and start to make sense out
of all that information and then on top
of that just the idea of data
complexities right we're dealing with a
lot of legacy applications data silos
right where finance has their own
different data sets and then you have
you know supply chain having known
different data sets but we know that we
need to stop merging that data so we can
actually start providing insights and
actually being more productive right
another thing is regulatory environments
right I mean there's been a lot of talk
within the last I want to say you're
just about GDP are and how does that
affect the data being collected by a lot
of the different organizations and then
finally just when you think about it
just the limited skills there's a lot of
demand for people who can actually start
to be able to do these type of analysis
and we're just seeing a lot of limited
skills so it's becoming very hard to
recruit and what's even more interesting
here is that this is a survey that was
done by Forrester this is actually done
just earlier this year right and we're
noticing that enterprises are very
interested in expanding the ability to
source extermo data
I think enterprises are realizing the
benefit of being able to augment the
existing data sets with external data
and so they know there's a lot of value
and how do we now start bringing that
data to these enterprises so that they
can actually start to to you know to get
more out of this so now I'll introduce
you to the public and commercial data
state program but again as you can
imagine we'll take a quick step back on
the left-hand side we're looking at a
tradition of data analytics platform
right in that type of platform we're
looking at organizations spending a lot
of time doing monitoring performance
tuning right making sure that their
systems are reliable resource
provisioning and then if you look at
once a person's doing all this then the
amount of time left to do analysis and
insights become so small however when
you look at on the right-hand side you
have the serve less data analytics model
and this is part of the Google cloud
platform right the idea here is that we
take away all those different
complexities and we let your people
focus on the things that they're good at
which is analysis and insights and so
again quick step back we'll look at you
know some of the different products that
we're providing as part of GCP right
we're providing a complete foundation
for data lifecycle all the way from the
points you're you're ingesting data
right with products like pub/sub and
data transfer service and all the way to
advanced analytics with a cloud ml
engine and then things like Google Data
studio and then of course we're also
providing the ability to be able to
orchestrate all these things with the
cloud composer which is just a product
that we've just recently launched so
again complete foundation for data
lifecycle and the idea here is that we
would like to have our customers really
focus again on analysis and insights and
really just you know it's almost like
let us do all the hard work for you you
know so now we'll do a quick
introduction on the public and
commercial data set program and the idea
behind these programs is that we're
we're looking to provide access to
datasets hosted on Google cloud platform
and what makes these these two programs
distinct is that users customers
organizations can access and analyze
structured and unstructured data in the
cloud without a need to move data the
idea here is that we've already provided
the data it's being hosted in you know
like bigquery in this case right and all
you have to do is pretty much come in
and access the data there the other
thing we're providing is a use of
Familia data warehouse in analytics
software things that you're very very
familiar with again if you're a big
query customer this should not be too
complicated for you it should feel very
very similar and then finally while also
providing is simple and easy to use
interface right again I've mentioned
data can be queried directly from the
bigquery web UI right the idea here is
we want to make this as easy as possible
to be able to have you start to create
insights and really get a lot of value
from data sets and so I'm sure you're
probably curious those were sort of sort
of like a similarities between the two
two programs now what are the
differences the first thing is that from
a public data set program perspective
data is really hosted and accessible to
customers in GCP again we host the data
for you all you have to do is just come
to GCP and you're able to access it from
a commercial data set perspective data
is hosted in GCP by data providers like
weather source right and standard GCP
user charges may apply the second
difference is that for public data set
program users can actually freely query
up to a terabyte of data per month
directly from the web UI again here it's
honestly it's free and then from a
commercial data set program users just
have to license the data set from the
data provider so in this case if you
were interested in accessing weather
data then all you would have to do is
trying to figure out how to license that
data again from weather source and once
you get access then you would definitely
just be able to access that directly in
BQ and then finally from public data set
what we're seeing a lot of people do is
it provides a playground for those new
to big data and data analysis because
again the data is public and it's also
freely hosted up to a terabyte of data
per month on the commercial data set
side what we're doing is we're providing
commercial data which has been curated
and vetted for analysis so in this case
weather source I've made sure that you
know this data is ready to be consumed
by you and so this creates a lot or a
lot of value for a lot of our customers
and here are some examples with the
different types of data sets we have
hosted on the left-hand side this is a
public data set so you know you you can
access things like github data Medicare
data Dow Jones data so it just depends
on what type of questions you're looking
to get answered and then on the
commercial data set side as you can
imagine where the source of course I
mean Ramin is ignite right these are
just a few of the providers that we have
hosted right now and we're also seeing
customers getting answers to a lot of
important questions right so if you're
looking to understand how real estate
effects traffic on long-term investments
in infrastructure then you would
probably want to access house canary
data which will be able to join with
your own data sets to be able to answer
these type of questions and then I'm
sure you're probably wondering how do
you access these data sets and I think
the one place that would like to send
you to is launcher so if you were just
to go to Google cloud launcher you
should be able to access these data sets
and here's just a quick snapshot of what
that looks like and then of course if
you're looking to get a lot a little bit
more information about the programs then
you could just go directly on our
website under commercial data sets in
Google cloud platform you can also
access the public data sets as well very
similarly so again just go ahead and
google it and you should be able to find
it all right so now I'll welcome Craig
to talk to us a little bit about what
it's worth Thank You Anita as anita
mentioned my name is or as I mentioned
earlier my name is Craig stomach I'm and
Veit senior vice president of business
development and weather source weather
sources at
nology company and since 2004 we've been
providing weather data and weather based
solutions to a wide range of businesses
in almost every industry it's
interesting a note that weather is
actually the largest external swing
factor in United States economics and
annually it results in over five hundred
billion in economic loss and other other
large large influences are in business
and in 2017 hurricane Harvey Irma in
Maria actually resulted in over two
hundred billion in economic loss and
there were countless lives lost
however despite acknowledging this in
understanding these numbers and the
impact of weather it amazes me every day
when I talk to large companies and small
and mid-sized businesses that do not use
weather as part of their overall weather
business strategy is this intelligence
strategy or don't even have a weather
strategy and that's where weather source
comes in and we're here to help
ours our weather data is essentially
statistically consistent homogeneous
data that is perfect for analytics in
unlike other data providers that
actually take Airport station data only
and interpolate or extend that data to
your location of interest weather source
approaches its data market ibly
different way we actually start with
your location of interest and then we
stage up to fifteen different inputs
including satellite radar local sensors
in a lot of mathematics and statistics
to essentially create a hyperlocal
weather station at your source or at
your location so that is truly hyper
local to your location and we're the
only data provider that has that
granular of weather data in our data
sets are perfect for analysis because
they are statistically consistent in a
homogeneous across space and time and
our two main data sets are on point
weather which is essentially a continuum
of data from the year 2000 hour by hour
day by day sorry let me move the slide
forward actually move it back sorry it's
so a continuum of data on point weathers
it can you continuum of data from
year 2002 present and with a forward
forecast view of up to 42 days on point
climatology is another data set and that
is essentially the statistics of weather
over time so that's gonna offer such
valuable information as what is normal
or average weather for any location at
any point in time which would be your
mean and what are your departures from
normal that's your standard deviations
and many times we find that most
businesses respond during those
departures from normal consumers you
know what consumers are gonna do when
it's 70 degrees out but what do they do
when it's 95 degrees up those are the
types of insights that can be gleaned
from OnPoint climatology and because
these datasets are homogeneous they
actually are perfect for analysis and
analytics consumers are able to actually
create baselines of business asset or
consumer behavior and then once you
establish those baselines you can
perform regressions using the past
weather data set to create scoring's of
rankings as to how your business
responds during those departures from
normal and then using forecast data you
can create a predictive model all within
GCP and all with using tools within GCP
to look forward and create an actionable
business in business intelligence and
weather based strategy so an OnPoint
weather an OnPoint climatology is
available for any lat launch point or
any geographically bounded area such as
zip or postal code and it is global and
we're on every landmass from the world
and up to to hunt and extend up to 200
miles offshore our weather our team our
weather sources superlative engineering
team also has the resources and
capability to assist with any modeling
or analytics project by a ensure that
you're obtaining the most actionable and
relevant business intelligence from the
use of our global weather data all of
our developers with the exception of one
are also duly trained meteorologists and
climatologists which is of great benefit
to our end-users we also offer free api
trial account sample data proof of
concept and we presently have three
sample data sets and bigquery that are
easy to act
says and that includes past weather data
climatology data and forecast weather
data and all of those are global we also
in addition offer turnkey solutions in
that example is our weather impact
ranking system worse for short which is
essentially a planning tool for weathers
impact on a business in words
essentially allows companies to monitor
all of their assets from a single pane
of glass and through a notification and
an alert function can stay in constant
communication with their customers staff
contractors or any relevant business
personnel need they are needed to make
an informed decision in the screen that
you're looking at here is just a sample
this particular customer was concerned
with various perils and the perils were
thunderstorms windstorm storm surge and
they had a significant amount of assets
in the Houston area so what worse does
from this single pane of glass allows
you to pot plot all of that businesses
locations you know a write in through
Google Maps API so you're constantly
monitoring real-time weather and what
its impact is and then when that weather
weather that exceeds the ranking
thresholds that we establish through
using our are statistically consistent
datasets you're able to then take take
appropriate action and some some
examples of appropriate action are I
know that I have a venue with outdoor
seating if I see hail present itself I'm
probably not going to have staff coming
in to work the outdoor outdoor seating
area because I'm not going to have
people customers using that area of my
business
so it's a great tool so we have the soup
to not switches we have the data we have
the middle which is the analytics
ability to assist with the modeling
project and then we have full-blown
solutions that actually ingest your data
and perform all the analysis for you and
monitor actively and in real-time in
some industries and that Moneta and I
talked about that could leverage weather
data our retail obviously with all
things Amazon and the change in our
landscape from brick-and-mortar to
e-commerce is essentially resulting in
retailers scrambling to
find ways to bring customers into their
locations
well weather is one of the largest in
influencers on when customers go
purchase things and so and there's other
ways like not only football traffic but
it's also seasonal and non seasonal
product sales knowing when to mark
products down if you mark products down
according to a predetermined date you
might end up with an unseasonable arms
fall and people might still be paying
full price or willing to pay full price
for that fall year prior to
transitioning into winter so we're able
to help retailers use our data to
quantify the impact of weather on their
cut on their consumers behavior
logistics in transportation
obviously logistics professionals their
number one concern is delivery of goods
from point A to point B in weather is
one of the largest disruptors of that
transit so our weather data allows
logistics professionals to plan for that
weather proactively and create steps or
take appropriate business response to
mitigate disruptions and in many cases
prevent disruptions travel and
hospitality is another great one it's
not only when customers are expected to
come to your facility but it's when not
to expect customers coming to your
facility we recently engaged with a
large sporting venue that had was
concerned about concession sales and
employees as related to tickets
conversions so what we did was we
analyzed weather patterns to find when
customers were not purchasing tickets
are not showing up to the venue and then
we created a predictive model so that
they when these weather events presented
themselves they could have less staff or
less concessions available in ultimately
saving this end-user a considerable
amount of money so there's all kinds of
ways that weather weather plays a plays
a very important role in business a
pretty pretty much across all businesses
pretty much every business has business
as weather sensitivities and as I said
earlier it's amazing that people aren't
leveraging weather data within the GCP
to create models to to take advantage
and proactively prepare for these type
of
their disruptions and and I think one of
the other things you had mentioned Craig
was the idea that how do you maybe
stretch uses whether data but also so
that you can understand the things that
are impacted by it right how do you
remove that you know within your
analysis right Oh see the impact of
other things that are not being affected
by weather
so you incorporating that data
absolutely so that's so that is another
method that we generally as we're doing
we're creating our models and in going
through the analysis with our customers
and the scoping what we generally do is
D weatherize the situation so we
actually use weather to find out whether
it's F actually a variable in impactful
for that particular business parameter
if we identify that then what we do is
we plan against that weather alter PSA's
if we do find that they have weather
sensitivities then we apply a predictive
model that's based on on on the weather
absolutely so great ok so now I'm going
to do a demo and the demo today the
objective my demo is basically to show
how weather data can play a role in
forecasting consumer search behavior and
how are you able to create better
forecast models using machine learning
all of this is being done in the Google
cloud platform and I'm a sales guy so
you'll see how easy it is and I'm hoping
to produce a meaningful results for you
and it's also another significant
overarching messages how easy it is to
use bigquery and actually pull large
data sets our data sets and bigquery
petabytes petabyte scale databases and
it's easy to pull data you know from
disparate sets of data join them and
then dumont perform modeling with them
and for this particular demo actually
I'm gonna have to go to my screen one
sick please so now I'm bringing up my
Google cloud platform and for this
particular demo and I've got I've
already pre-loaded some things so you
don't have to be bored with with with me
loading things but I'm essentially I
launched this with Google cloud launcher
and I'm right now in the Google cloud
platform and I use three GUI and I'm
using google trends search data and I
use three weather sensitive search terms
and I used air conditioner
flew and in snow tires and I use three
weather values and those weather values
were feels like temperature
precipitation and snowfall those and I
was over the period of seven years so
with seven years of data both on Google
Trends and and for my past weather data
and and I'm using the entire state of
Massachusetts where I'm based as my DMA
or designated Market area so in advance
of this demo I downloaded my Google
Trends data into CSV files and I
uploaded into bigquery and so now I'm
basically I launched my google compute
instance and what you're looking now is
what you're looking at now is
essentially I'm gonna open my data lab
instance so very simply i activate my
cloud shell which is going to give me my
command prompt and this was the delay
I'm talking about so sorry
was sternly and sorry I have to start my
incidents first so like I said I'm not
the technical person so my technical
people set this up for me still starting
so I just put in and we've created like
I said my data lab instance prior in
data lab is actually a full lifestyle
workbench that allows you to analyze
visualize and manipulate data including
creating learning models all within GCP
so very very robust application so now
it's going to prompt me to change my
port so I'm waiting for my data lab
instance to load sorry Anita but I just
wanted to show everybody how easy it is
and how this is all within the Google
ecosystem so open my web preview change
my port to eight zero eight one and now
it's going to open a new window which is
going to be my data lab instance so so
so now it's opening up my Jupiter
notebook and Jupiter is essentially also
found within the GCP and Jupiter is an
integrated development environment
that's fully accessible within within
the GCP and allows me to create Python
pipe scripts that are easy to run in use
so now in in essentially I'm running all
my code also using Google Cloud Data Lab
now first step is going to be I'm
importing my libraries and I'm using
Python pandas for my data manipulation
mat plot live for my data visualization
in scikit-learn for my machine learning
again all of these are found within a
Google cloud platform and accessible
within Google Cloud data lab so very
simply I hit shift and enter and it's
going to run that and again very low
latency I am on a guest network right
now but now I'm going to approve my
Google trend and weather data from
bigquery and I'm going to join the data
now I'm doing this by running a simple
join using the date in my disparate
tables within bigquery
so again being able to pull this data
easily and seamlessly all within
bigquery
now I'm going to create my training and
training and testing data set and I'm
used for this demo I used a traditional
machine learning approach where I
divided the day to 80% for my training
20% for my testing you know shift and
enter very very simple even a sales guy
can follow it so now I'm going to create
a simple machine learning model and I'm
using a random forest regression so that
is a common machine learning regression
approach and if you remember my target
variables are flu air conditioner and
snow tires in my three weather
parameters R feel like temperature
snowfall and precipitation so again you
can see how quickly this is and again
these are machine learning models and
it's performing literally in seconds so
now I'm gonna create my random forest
regressor that's performing my analysis
now I will fit my model and then with
the training data and once the model is
trained it's ready to use for predictive
analytics and so now I will actually run
my fitted model on my test data and if
you recall I reserved 20% of my data for
the testing and now all of my modeling
and testing is complete and my entire
model has been trained and I'm ready for
my visualizations so again it's
seamlessly all doing this within the
data lab so I essentially created a
model I queried bigquery I joined the
data I ran it through created or
predictive model and now I'm visualizing
it so as you can see what you're looking
at here is the Google trend in the the
predicted value is the green and the
blue is the actual true Google data so
as you can see even with this relatively
simple exercise a lot of these you see
very very strong correlations between
obviously consumer search behavior and
and weather and although obviously we're
using weather sensitive terms as anita
mentioned earlier this could be used for
non weather sensitive terms to kind of D
weather eyes and find out if there is
any impact
and that could be something of removing
that variable of weather and my Google
with air conditioning is even more
telling and what's really significant
about this slide is the spikes because
this is showing the the how strong of an
influence weather has on Google on
consumer search behavior and ultimately
consumer purchasing and then the last
model that I have to visualize is my
snow tire example and as you can see we
still see very very mean this is even
more solace
with snow tires and it's interesting we
can actually tell you that 80 plus
percent of your snow tires are sold on
the first instance of a snow forecast
and then there's a dampening effect that
occurs over the subsequent three months
so in the fourth month you're really
selling less than 2% of your snow tires
but again I'm not showing that with this
demo what I'm showing with this
particular site is just these strong
correlations and clearly you can see how
easy it is to create a machine learning
model using weather within Google cloud
platform and using bigquery and these
strong correlations really show clearly
show the influence of weather and
consumer search behavior absolutely and
I think for some of these organizations
it starts to stir to provide you with a
way to to figure out when to spend money
right if you're looking at when do you
actually you know ump up you know things
like advertising right and when did when
do you ask for funds when do you not
right and I think if you know that's the
first couple months is when you know
snow tires will be sold most then that's
probably when you should actually be
increasing advertising is that right
exactly and you know back to your asthma
example um you know and another great
example with asthma is because with the
climatology data having the normal or
average weather data you're able to look
for anomalies so when the forecast shows
that it is an anomaly over what is true
or act true or average or normal weather
a company that sells asthma medications
when they understand what triggers
asthma precipitation humidity pollen
things like that if they recognize that
they have an anomaly they can move in
to a region and start advertising in
advance of the competition so
understanding when consumers are going
to buy allows you to get the leg up and
essentially put you know deploy
marketing or other resources in that
region to make sure you're you you have
a competitive advantage over your over
your competition absolutely and if you
think about it too for that
pharmaceutical company what's even more
interesting is that now they can
actually start to provide patient care
before things happen right because you
you have good predictive models of when
you know things like allergens things
like humidity things like temperature
and how those are impacting somebody who
has asthma and can you now actually
start to provide patient care before
even those things happen and that
becomes really powerful for for an
organization or even for a company
business absolutely thank you so much
Craig I think I think that was very
eye-opening so we will jump quickly and
just I think the biggest takeaway here
is the idea that we realized that a lot
of organizations are not going to be
able to source every single type of data
that they need to do their analysis
right and this is where things like
public and commercial data's of programs
hosted on GCP become very very powerful
again just to quickly summarize data is
available immediately so in a public
data set scenario honestly that's
immediately for commercial data sets as
soon as you finish doing the licensing
with a data provider then you can access
data directly within GCP secondly data
is ready for analysis within the cloud
products again I think we've Craig has
done a great job showcase showcasing
some of those products like the bigquery
UI right I think we've talked a little
bit about data lab but these are these
are products that you're very familiar
with and they're the same ones you'll be
using to access the public and
commercial datasets and then finally I
think to reiterate here is this the idea
of you getting more value from a growing
data ecosystem right I think one of the
things we talked about is that there is
increasing plethora of just data out
there right but how do we start helping
our customers be able to access the data
when they wanted and make that process
easier I think one of the things I keep
hearing about is this idea of
democratizing right data and insights
and this is what this program does so
again thank you for joining us stay
tuned for live Q&A we'll be back in less
than a minute
you
welcome back to the live audience Q&A so
the first question we got from the
audience is how much does it cost to
build out the model you presented Craig
sure so the cost to build out that model
would be relatively small you know
generally when we engage on an analytics
project we take a look at what the end
user is looking for with respect to
output and then we back in essentially
time and materials so for an example for
a something a model like this would be
you know several thousand dollars but
they can go all the way up to if a
business has ten thousand SKUs and they
want regressions performed against each
one of those skills you're looking at a
different price point but our data is
extremely competitive and as you know
Google cloud platform operates on the
consumption based model so any of these
models are you know you're only paying
for what you use and then with our data
we price by essentially location so it's
really how many locations and and again
for an analysis like that how many
products you're talking about and what
is the end user attempting to accomplish
but we are very very cost competitive
and we do not lose against price so good
to do ok another question for you Craig
so clarify what cloud data lab is and
what its benefits I think for a lot of
our customers well maybe not too
familiar with that product
sure so cloud life cloud data lab is a
full life cycle cycle workbench that
essentially allows you to take data
analyze it transform it manipulate it
model including creation of machine
learning models and visualize all within
Google cloud platform so you're never
having to leave one ecosystem to go into
another makes it very very easy all of
your work is saved there you can share
and collaborate across your entire
business you can share those
visualizations to other people so it's
just a great program to essentially do
everything but that's a very small piece
as you know of Google Cloud compute but
it is a very very robust environment
yeah great
ok so how is GCP different than other
business intelligence platforms and I
think the first thing that I would say
is this idea of providing to our acosta
and end-to-end data lifecycle management
right the idea of that we have products
that will help you ingest the data right
store the data in all all the way to
start doing things like predictive
analytics right and so you're you're
nodding happy you're not having to move
your data somewhere else all that is
stored within the query and you're able
to do this end-to-end lifecycle of data
management I think that's one big one
and I think the the next big one is this
idea that we would like our customers to
focus on analysis and insights right so
we take away all the complexity of you
know performance tuning resource
provisioning right I think I shown a
little bit of that a little bit earlier
but the idea is we would like to make
this data and less analysis as easy and
as seamless as possible for a lot of our
customers all right so last question is
how easy is it to get started to be
predictive analytics what do you think
Craig well it it's not very easy but
obviously and it's not very easy to
actually work with weather data because
there's a lot of nuances with weather
data so analytics is hard predictive
analytics is hard
adding weather data adds a level of
complexity but again you know weather
source is is in in the GCP Google cloud
platform resources are also there's a
ton of resources available to help you
get started and so weather sort of says
the capabilities to help you get moving
on any type of predictive analytic
project as does the in the sales were
the support reps for for Google cloud
platform so great thank you so much for
watching please tune in next Tuesday put
the next cloud Renier